hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
seite gibt es was ganz ganz leckeres ich
mache heute nämlich orio cheesecake
macht und es klingt ja schon so richtig
lecker und deswegen zeigt sich einfach
ganz schnell die zutaten damit wir
gleich wissen wie das funktioniert
ich brauche für den boden oreo kekse und
habe da jetzt etwa 180 gramm
ich brauche aber später nur 120 gramm
ich werde nämlich hier noch ihnen die
füllungen auskratzen und ihr könnt ihr
aber auch andere kekse nehmen wie zum
beispiel von keksen oder butterkekse
falls ihr keine rollt hier etwas zu
lassen butter das sind 50 gramm
und dann brauchen wir für die füllung
frischkäse doppel rahmen stoff bei 400
gramm 100 gramm zucker eine packung
crème fraiche dessen 200 gramm etwas
zitronenschale abrieb und ein bisschen
zitronensaft 2 eier und ich habe hier
noch etwas vanilleschote und es waren
schon die zutaten und ich sag mal ich
starte einfach direkt mit dem teig oder
mit dem boden und nehme jetzt dafür die
kekse
und wetzel jetzt wie gesagt einfach mal
rasieren
das geht ja ganz gut wie in der werbung
einfach auftreten und dann hier innen
diese creme auskratzen die brauchen wir
jetzt nicht die könnte dann anderweitig
verwenden führt zum beispiel ein cupcake
talking oder ihr könnt sie einfach so
auf essen wobei sie relativ süß ist die
kekse habe ich jetzt in einem
gefrierbeutel gegeben und werde jetzt
mit einem nudelholz drüber rollen um sie
zu zerkleinern könnte aber auch zum
beispiel in einem mixer machen da geht's
schneller aber ich will es jetzt einfach
so machen weil man für diesen kuchen
auch gar keine küchenmaschine
was machst du denn ich liebe die creme
dachten ja max lässer gerne durchschnitt
viel arbeit abgenommen meister wieso er
weil ich die immer dann praktisch die
keks auseinandergenommen cup und die
creme
echt jetzt dann sind wir zwei das
perfekte team karima ich nämlich die
kekse ohne creme hey cool
also wenn ihr eine freundin wirkt oder
einen mann oder einen partner der die
creme gern mag ich würde es nur die
kicks bruegel ist perfekt ich gebe jetzt
die keks brösel in eine kleine schale
hinein und ihr seht ich habs jetzt nicht
komplett zerkleinert mit einem mixer
bilden sie jetzt auch komplett klein
gemacht werden aber das braunwald auch
gar nicht und hier gebe ich jetzt die
geschmolzene butter mit und mischt
diesen brösel hoffen jetzt zusammen
dann ist jetzt einfach gucken dass die
butter überall dran kommt ich habe
dieses rezept auch schon mal mit dem
mixer gemacht da geht es natürlich viel
schneller die keks brüssel sind so in 5
5 sekunden klein und dann ist auch die
butter direkt unter gemengt so dauert
einfach ein bisschen länger
aber hier ist das endergebnis
und so sehen dann die keks brüssel mit
der butter mischung aus und hier habe
ich mir zu machen backblech vorbereitet
und bereits mit papier förmchen
ausgelegt und da fühle ich jetzt jeweils
etwa einen esslöffel von dieser brösel
masse hinein
das sieht jetzt erst mal ziemlich viel
aus aber wir drücken dass jetzt auch
gleich noch platz und dann wird es ein
richtig schöner knuspriger brösel wurden
und so schokoladig und dann können wir
jetzt den keks boden mit so einem teil
hier flach drücken wenn ihr sowas nicht
habt könnte auch ein glas nehmen das
geht auch gut ich hab das jetzt
neuerdings auch bei mir im shop das hat
nämlich ein großes in großen kleines
ende und da kann ich kleine muffin
förmchen und auch große damit rein
drücken und dann wird es einfach flach
gedrückt und dann haben wir dann richtig
schönen uppsala festen boden
da geht's jetzt natürlich besser wenn
die keks brösel ganz fein gemahlen sind
aber die sich auch so gar kein problem
und wenn ihr die keks brösel dann
vorbereitet habt könnt ihr die creme zu
bereiten und das geht jetzt auch alles
ohne elektrisches handrührgerät braucht
man nun schneebesen dafür
dafür nehme ich jetzt erstmal meinen
frischkäse und dann ist da wirklich
darauf achten dass es einen doppelnamen
käse ist weil die light-version einfach
zu wenig fett haben und dann die maßen
viel zu flüssig wird
da gebe ich den zucker mit rein und die
vanilleschote und falls ihr keine
vanilleschoten habt neben der einfach
ein bisschen vanille zucker am besten
den test gemacht noch die zitronenschale
ableiten
ich finde die muster auf jeden fall mit
rein einfach für so ein bisschen so eine
zitronige note weil es ansonsten nur
nach vanille und schokolade schmeckt und
das macht das ganze ein bisschen
frischer könnten aber auch zum beispiel
millimetern
dann wird es kurz verrührt
dann gebe ich da noch die eier mit dazu
und noch die creme fraiche unfalls ihr
kennt creme fraiche da habt könnt ihr
auch gerne schmandt nehmen und das
sollte es ganz einfach noch cremiger
machen und wir nehmen jetzt kein
elektrisches hand zurück gerät weil es
ist ja eher so ein amerikanisches
rezepten amerikanischer cheesecake und
der schäden nicht so locker wie unser
deutscher käsekuchen sondern eher cremig
und deswegen wollen wir da keine luft
rein sondern wollen das ganze schön
cremig halten
und sobald sich alles was mit stadt ist
diese macht dann auch schon fertig und
typischen sehr schnelles rezept wie man
jetzt aussieht
und jetzt kann ich die förmchen damit
befüllen und die könnte jetzt auch schön
rand hochgefühle
weil ihr die käsemasse jetzt auch nicht
weiter aufgeht und damit sich das ganze
jetzt noch hier schön verteilt knüpfen
wird ein bisschen und so kriegen wir
auch die restliche luft raus und so
werden jetzt die muffins bei 150 grad
für etwa 20 bis 22 minuten gebacken
es kommt natürlich auf euren oben drauf
an sie sollten auf jeden fall wenn sie
fertig sind in der mitte - ein bisschen
wackelig sein
das zeigt sich aber gleich ich zeige
euch jetzt mal die fertigen muffins und
zwar sieht man jetzt hier deutlich dass
sie in der mitte noch etwas waffeln und
so dürfen sie jetzt auch sein und so
muss ich jetzt einfach komplett
auskühlen lassen am besten bei
zimmertemperatur ganz kurz abkühlen
lassen und dann für etwa zwei stunden in
den kühlschrank geben
und wenn die macht man einigermaßen
abgekühlt sind können dass er einfach
aus stürzen weil so kriegt man dir
bisschen schlecht raus wir sind als
einfach so ein abkühlen gitter setz ist
drauf und dreht einmal um
dann kommen die man schön raus und was
sieht auch schön die schwarze und weiße
farbe und dann kann man sie einfach
umdrehen und dann stelle ich sie noch
mal ganz was im kühlschrank meine
muffins ist schön abgekühlt und richtig
kalt mal können sie jetzt so servieren
und zu lassen
aber ich möchte sie noch mit einer
himbeere ganze reihe erfüllung befüllen
damit sie einfach ein bisschen auch
fruchtiger schmecken und ich noch so ein
farbklecks oben drauf habe und das
könnte natürlich nicht nur mit himbeeren
machen sondern auch mit anderen früchten
wir brauchen 70 gramm himbeeren das netz
tiefgekühlte kam aber auch frische
nehmen je nach saison ein teelöffel
speisestärke einen esslöffel zucker und
etwa 40 milliliter wasser oder man kann
da auch einfach einen likör nehmen oder
einen saft und es geht jetzt ziemlich
schnell
ich gebe mich einfach alles in einen
kleinen topf
hier früher ich jetzt noch die
speisestärke mit dem wasser und gibt es
jetzt direkt zu den himbeeren dazu und
die werden jetzt hier im topf bisschen
an town deswegen vielleicht nicht auf
höchster stufe
und dann werde ich sie einfach nur noch
feuchte
und wenn es dann aufgekocht ist ist es
schon fertig man kann das jetzt so
verwenden oder man gibt es noch durch
ein sieb dann haben wir nämlich die
kernel ist dabei und das mache ich jetzt
ganz kurz ich will nämlich dass es
richtig schön samtig wird
jetzt nehme ich mir einfach irgendeinen
kleinen löffel ich nehme jetzt den von
meinem esslöffeln her und zwar nehme ich
den alten teelöffel und schreitet hier
in die mitte so ein kleines loch rein
machen und dann gleich die hinterfüllung
rhein geben
ihr könnt sie aber auch wenn ihr wollt
einfach als frucht spiegel obendrauf
geben wo man sieht jetzt auch schon wie
schön cremig hier
diese käsemasse ist
und dann könnte einfach die
hinterfüllung hinein für ganz vorsichtig
so sind die muffins fertig und man kann
selbst theoretisch so servieren
oder man nimmt sich zum beispiel solche
cache raps die haben wird neuerdings
auch bei uns und da kann man die muffins
richtig schön rein stellen man sieht
dann von auf und war nicht mehr in
diesen schönen schwarzen rand den
amtmann wo noch aber ich finde die echt
hübsch und zwar sind es solche die legt
man dann einfach zusammen kann sie hier
hinten verschließen
ganz einfach und dann lässt man den
muffin einfach reinfall
wenn ich so ein fall
die den total lecker aus aber eine ganz
wichtige frage die ist vermessen
yakari man sagt dass man könnte jetzt
entweder das papier außenrum entfernen
können wir mal einmal machen oder löffel
oder gefilmt
wenn man entfernt kann man es ja auch
ohne das papier servieren finde ich auch
hübsch und man sieht auch der boden hält
ja auch zusammen
dann könnte man das theoretisch auf
einen teller setzen oder einfach so aus
der hand essen geht ja ganz gut
oder man kann es einfach rauslassen
das geht auch hier ist ein problem gerne
lassen oder bei ich glaube ich laufen
das war eine gute idee
weil der schießt kann sich auch nicht so
süß schmeckt weil der frisch geht es ein
bisschen salzig
eigentlich mag ich das auch nicht so
wendel frischkäse als creme nimmst ich
hatte mal so richtig kommt häufig rufen
gemacht mit frischkäse creme der war
aber gar nicht mir jetzt nicht
geschmeckt aber das finde ich jetzt
somit in kombination als gut alternativ
für die euro krise könnte man auch muss
man halt nur vorher die creme entfernen
und die würde ich gerne meinen job und
wenn ihr möchtet
ich habe übrigens auch noch so leckere
fähnchen sagen ich schon schöne fähnchen
kann man die zum beispiel auch noch
richtig cool dekorieren mit seinem mini
fähnchen dran
kann man da oben
durchgekämpft
gibt es ganz verschiedene muster finde
ich echt goldig ja und das rezept gibt
es zum nachlesen auch salehs blog.de die
artikel die verlinken einfach in der
infobox falls die euch interessieren
und ich würde ganz gerne wissen was ist
denn euer lieblings keks wir haben es
eben schon hinter der kamera die
diskussion
also ich mag zwar oder kekse aber ich
mag zum beispiel noch viel mehr dass
unser türkische kekse mit einer
schokofüllung drin weil die
schokofüllung so lecker schokolade
schmeckt was denn eigentlich deine
lieblings somit kalter wind ja das würde
ich auch ganz gern wissen und ich
wünsche euch auf jeden fall ganz viel
spaß beim nachbacken und freue mich
darüber wenn ich mir fotos auf instagram
oder facebook schickt wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder bis bald